Rocket?
Rocket, are you there?
What are you doing Peter?
Dance with me
I'm not going to dance with you
This is Sam Cooke
One of the greatest
earth singers of all time
Drax thinks you're not a dancer
If you ever tell anyone about this,
I will kill you
Hope you're ready
It'll be here any minute
Is that a rifle?
You don't know
what a rifle looks like?
it's just swords were
your thing and guns were mine
But I guess we're both
doing guns now
I just didn't know that
Oh, that's intense
Arrrghh
[Evil laugh]
[music]
I see it within you
Fear
Jealousy
Betrayal
It is our duty
To cleanse the universe of this weakness
You know, they told me you people
were conceited douchbags
But that isn't true at all
Dude
Arh, I'm using my wrong eye
Groot, put your seatbelt on
So we're saving
the galaxy again?
Yeap
Awesome
We're really going to be able to jack up our
price as two time galaxy savers
Die spaceship!
Fight!
Sometimes the thing you're
searching for your whole life
it's right there by your side all along
You're right
All you do is yell at each other
You're not friends
No, we're family
Except maybe her
After all these years, I've found you
And who the hell are you?
I'm your dad Peter